Let's  get
this show on the road. We are
1700 on the nose.
Definitely the level of our
opposition has been
rising steadily. Let's see who
we face tonight.
Anita
Kakari
four.    And in the speedrun I
play    my official opening
recommendations, we still have not gotten an
accelerated dragon. This is actually kind of
fascinating how few people
play the Open Sicilian. And again,
we're not getting an accelerated we're
getting night C Three.
And every time we face night C
Three, which is a couple of times now,
I sort of reiterate the explanation
of which move you should play in
response. And that depends
primarily on what you play
against the Open Sicilian. So if
you're a Nydarf player, then you should play
D Six. If you're an accelerated dragon
player, which we are for the purposes of
this speed run, then you
should play the move knight to C Six. The
point is that if White now plays the move
knight F, uh, three, which she just did,
how should we proceed with
luck? Well, of course, we should basically
play with the understanding
that our opponent is going to play D Four on
the next move.   So
if we're an accelerated dragon player, then
everything is very easy. We play G Six,
and in the event of D Four, which I think
is quite likely, we take, and then we
transpose directly into an accelerated
dragon. Very nice. Our first
one.   Okay.
Bishop. G Seven. Fiancadowing. The
bishop.   And this is our
first accelerated dragon. And it makes sense
we've hit 1700. This is
around the time
that we see more people
delve into some of the main lines.
All right, so in the
Accarda Dragon, the kind of
Zen of this opening is to
delay the move D Six. If we
play D Six, then we allow
White to transpose into the
mainline dragon. And there's nothing
cardinally wrong with the dragon itself.
It's just a highly theoretical and
incredibly dangerous opening. The
accelerated dragon essentially does not
allow White to castle Queenside without
suffering the consequences. So we hold
off on the move D Six. Why
do we do that? Well, we do that primarily so
that we can play
D, open up the
center in one fell swoop, provided that
White allows this to happen. Therefore, we
develop our knight first.
And if you're seeing this for the first
time, you know, uh, you might
be worried about the prospect
of developing our minor pieces without
first pushing our pawn out to D
Six. But as I'll show you after the
game, this is nothing to worry about.
And there is a line where White tries to
punish us by trading on C Six
and then playing E Five. But in
that line, black successfully sacrifices
a pawn with the knight D Five and gets
a very nice initiative. This is a well known
line. According to theory,
A Three is already a
sideline. In fact, it's a move that I have
never seen before. It's not a very good
move. And it's not a very good
move because it doesn't really do anything.
I mean, A three in this position is sort of
a waste of time because we are
not planning to put
anything on B Four.
So we can essentially
proceed as though White has given us
another turn
and we could probably already get
away with the move D five. But the
problem with playing D Five before
castling is that after D Five, there
is the very unpleasant move bishop B
five. And you can kind of see
why that's annoying. White pins the night.
White threatens knight takes C six, and then
bishop takes C Six is going to fork the king
and the rook. So, as a general rule of
thumb, um, you only want to play D Five.
After you've Castled Kingside, which is what
we're going to do. We're going to castle
kingside. We are now fully ready to
push the pond to D Five and open up the
center. And we can really try to
punish White for delaying her
development here. Bishop c four. Okay,
now, a very important tactical
detail, and this is
incredibly common in the accelerated dragon.
It is impossible to play the
accelerated without
knowing this concept. And
this is called the center fork
trick.   And the center fork
trick is
ubiquitous across many different
openings and with both colors, which
makes it incredibly important to know. And
it occurs any time either
side has a bishop on this
square. Or, of course, if you're playing
black, you have a bishop on C
five, right? This is the precondition
for the center fork trick.
And what you do is actually
knight takes C Four anyway.
Looks like a blunder. But, uh,
if you have prior knowledge of this idea,
you know that it's not a blunder. Knight
takes C four, you meet with the move D
five. That's where the fork term comes
from. And you essentially ref
fork the knight and the bishop,
and you're going to win the piece back. Now,
White can give that piece
away for a pawn, but in
this particular version, it's not even that
easy for White to win the pawn back, as
you'll see. So we play the move. D five. A
couple of things to notice again,
mostly if you're seeing this for the first
time,   if White plays the move
knight takes night, then we take
back with the pawn. And even though White
has opened up a line of contact
to the D Five pawn, we are now
protecting it with our own, uh, C
Six pawn. So this is an important detail.
This is indeed exactly what happens.
And this is where White really, really pays
the price, uh, for the move A
three, because it is more common
for this position to arise
with White having castled
instead of having played A three. So
White keeping the king in the center and
essentially wasting a move
is really going to burn them.
So what's going
on here? Well, we're attacking the bishop
and the night at the same time, hence the
fork. And the general kind of
prescription for
responding to the center fork trick is to
keep your bishop pair.
Books often recommend this, and this is the
best move in a lot of different openings.
The move bishop c four back to d three
is often the recommended way of
combating the center fork trick.
And the point is that after we take the
night, white takes back the pawn and keeps
their bishop pair. But if
you look a little bit further in this
particular situation,   the b two
pawn is also hanging, and it's hanging with
tempo. We take it and we attack the
rook simultaneously. So that's kind of
out the window.  That's kind of out the
window. And if white's not playing bishop d
three, then what is white doing? Well, white
can probably take on D five, but
then we recapture with the pawn. And again
we have the bishop pair. We're attacking the
knight. The knight can't move back to C
three because white gets forked again, this
time on the fourth rank. And if
white doesn't move to C three, then again,
white loses the b two pawn with tempo.
So there's just nothing that white can do
which comes even remotely close to
equalizing nike three is her choice.
Okay,
well, what do
we do now? Well, a very bad move
here would be to play bishop takes B
two. And I think, uh, newer players might be
tempted by the look of that move because
you might say, well, let's grab that pawn
and attack the rook. And when the rook
moves, then we can take the bishop. The
problem is, remember that we have already
sacrificed a piece. So bishop takes
b two, allows white to move the bishop away
from C four. And if we then take
the rook on a one, white takes back with a
queen. And technically
black is even up material in the resulting
position because we have a rook and two
pawns for the two pieces. But in most
middle game situations, two
pieces are preferable to a rook.
And you particularly want to avoid,
when possible, giving
away   your fianceto
bishop in the accelerated
dragon unless you absolutely have to
or unless there are some sort of extenuating
circumstances. So bishop takes b two would
be bad. We simply
recapture on c four. Now we are
up a pawn. Okay. Our opponent gets
into an end game.   And
of course, we will still need to show a good
amount of technique if we want
to finish our opponent off
in style here. Now, c three is a good
move by our opponent closing off our
bishop.   And now that the queens
are off the board, we need to kind of
reassess the situation we are upon.
We have a bishop pair, our bishop on C
eight is not yet developed.
But because the queens are off the board,
our king is not in any imminent danger.
It's not like we need to necessarily
rush to get our bishop out. I think we
have bigger fish to fry here. And the
particular fish that I think we should
fry is this B two pawn. What
makes me look at the B two pawn? Well,
largely it's the fact that we have a pond on
C four. And from some of my
endgame videos, you might recognize this as
kind of a deep freeze situation where one
of your pawns is essentially
keeping in place, holding down two or
more of the enemy pawns. So
that pawn on C four is making
sure that the pawn on B two is not only a
backward pawn, but has no
path forward. That pawn is a
huge weakness, and it's a weakness on
an open file. So there is a move that's
essentially begging to be played. And this
is a move we can play largely without
calculation because there isn't anything to
lose by playing this move. And
I am thinking of the move rook to B
eight. Now, you might say, well, what about
the A seven pawn? Well, that pawn cannot
be captured because if I would have captured
it, we would have taken B two, and
then the C three pawn very
likely would have also fallen. Rook
B one is just collapsed by our
opponent.   The rook on B one
is unprotected. LPDO loose
pieces drop off. And I
know this because the rooks are not
coordinated. And the move that
just ends the game here is
bishop takes E three. Check.
I can sense some people
wondering if we can first play rook takes B
two and try to be fancy. The answer is
no. The answer is no. Rook takes b
two. Rook takes b two. Bishop takes
c three. Check. The rook can block on
D two. It's a common type of
blunder. The rook that you're forking
can itself block the check.
And after takes takes black
emerges down a piece.   So bishop C three
is simple and strong. Now we have two
possibilities. We can play bishop takes
B two. Or I think the more
clinical move is to play rook takes B two.
We're already up essentially three pawns.
So you should already have one eye on
Simplification.   And trading a pair of
rooks will make it easier for us,
as a consequence, to promote the C
four pawn. So I like the
move. Rook takes b two.
And this is already game over.
Our first accelerated
Dragon experiment has been a successful
one.
Yeah. Bishop takes b two. White
is probably going to take on a seven.
We're going to play C three, obviously.
And the good thing about C
three is that it not only prepares to
promote the pawn, it also creates an anchor
point for our, uh, rook on D
two. And it opens up the
A six F one diagonal for our LightSquared
bishop. So we solve all of the problems with
that move.   Yes. C three we can.
Again, at this point, I'm playing largely
without calculation  because there's nothing
to calculate. None of our moves contain any
risk at all. They're just
incredibly straightforward
and essentially asking to be
played. Yeah, of course we can take a three.
There's nothing inherently wrong with
grabbing another pawn, but we can grab
that pawn now if we wanted to. But I'm just
trying to win the game in a more efficient
manner.   Now, here's
the order of operations. Of course.
The, uh,  move that's begging
to be played here is C two, and we're going
to play it. But C Two doesn't
actually threaten to promote. What
does C two threaten?
So try to figure out what
threat does C two actually
pose. And we're going to play this move
next against virtually
any one of White's responses.
So not rook D One
immediately, because if we play rook D one
immediately, white takes on D
one. And then perhaps some of you are
attracted to bishop G four. Check. But
remember that White can block that with a
pawn.  Instead, we need to switch
the move order. We want to go rook D one,
but we want to dislodge the king from E two
first. And if you've been paying attention,
this move should occur to you. Bishop a six.
Check. Knock the king off of E
two, then put the rook on D
one, and the path is now essentially
clear for the pawn to promote. We can either
promote immediately and win a piece,
or we can try to squeeze a little
bit more out of the situation   by
deflecting the bishop off of this diagonal.
If we can do that, then the promotion comes
and we simply make a new queen.
Yeah, this is,
uh,   a pretty one sided
game.
Yeah, this has
been a very one sided game. Age three. Okay,
so again,     if
you're playing a blitz game,
then there's nothing wrong with just taking
the rook and then making a
queen and getting up a
bishop and a pawn and converting
the resulting position. But, uh,
we're trying to be as accurate as possible.
I'm trying to give you a glimpse of what GM
level play actually looks like. And so we're
going to put into practice an idea that
I think might be a lot less obvious to
people. This might be one of the least
obvious ideas of this game.   What we're
going to do, essentially, is use our
pawns on the kingside to
squeeze the life out of White's minor
pieces the knight on G three and the bishop
on E three. First of all, this is
something everybody should see are on
forkable squares.
What could they be forked by?
Well, there's only one thing that could fork
them, and that's a pawn. Now, on what square
would the pond have to be? Well, the pawn
would have to be on the F, uh, four square.
But that seems pretty far fetched, right? It
seems like we're not even close to being
able to establish a pawn in F Four, and yet
that's an illusion. We're only three
moves away, and we've got all the time
in the world here because White is
totally paralyzed. And that's the
beauty of
being able to do what you want.
So we're simply
going to start with E Five,
and then on the next move, we're going to
play F Five.   And the problem
isn't only that we will be threatening F
four, we will also be threatening E Four.
And that's almost checkmate.
And even if White moves one of the minor
pieces, f Four might still be
incredibly effective. So, for
instance,   as we play the move
F Five here, if White moves the bishop
seemingly out of
sight of the FPA, we will still play F
Four. And that bishop on H Six,
its contact with C One is going to be
intercepted. That's even better.
And white is no squares. That's it.
Resigns.   So, a simple
idea.   I, uh, didn't mean to
overhype it, but I think it ends the game a
lot faster than promoting
immediately.  That one was
pretty fast.
Let's quickly go through some of the
introductory theory, and I'm sure we will
get more accelerated Dragon Games
as we go along. So I'm not going to
bog you down too much in any individual
game.      So knight C,
six,   knight
F. So we transposed into a main
line here. Bishop G, seven.
Previously. We'd gotten a closed Sicilian.
We'd gotten Grand Prix attack. We'd gotten a
good amount of antisilians. Okay?
Bishop B Three, of course, is the main move.
Now we play Nite F six. And the sort of
introductory line that I'd like to show
here is knight takes C Six,
BC and E Five, because this
is a very important line
to know.    This is
a very important line to know. And I'll pull
up what I have here.   Just a
moment.    Yeah. So
here, if you don't know what to do with
Black, you are likely
to kind of sink under the weight of this E
Five pawn. As far as I know, Black has two
moves. Let me check which one is more
popular nowadays. Yeah. Nine. G Eight is
actually the move. I
apologize. Uh, what I said during the game
was wrong. N Five is
not the correct way to play here,
even though it's an interesting pawn
sacrifice. But believe it or not, you
actually move the knight back to Ga.
Now, F Four is what
most people are going to play here.
And it's important to realize that
despite the sort of appearance,
despite, uh,   appearances,
black's position is completely
fine. And White has
bitten off more of a chunk of the
center than he can
chew. Black has a couple of interesting
moves here. There's F, uh, six chipping away
at the center immediately. But
I like the move knight H six,
redeploying the knight along the light
squares that White has weakened on the
kingside, which is a common
byproduct of this particular pawn chain.
The light squares on the kingside are
now quite weak. So here
the main move is queen D two.
And you can start by castling
short.    And let's
say that White Castle's queenside. There are
still over 100 games in the database.
Now we have to chip away
at White's pawn chain with the
move D six.   Now, uh, this
seems to give up a pawn, and it does. But
now you've opened up your bishop and the
bishop is joined by the knight, which comes
out to F five. But the
main drawback of taking on C
six in any such position
is that it opens the B file. And the
B file is an absolute
game changer in any position with opposite
side castling. Watch how quickly
that open B file can lead to White's
demise. So let's say White plays
de     queen E
seven.      The
bishop has to move because it's now hanging
bishop F two. And already
here, rook B eight is a great
move. But rook B eight is not the best
move. And this is subtle, but hopefully
everybody can understand it. Here. White can
play. Bishop C. Four. And the point of
bishop C four is to drop the
bishop back to B three and,
uh, block the B file.
So this move is very tempting, but black
is at a bit of a dead end. It's
worthwhile to start with the move bishop to
E six, cover the C four square, and
pre move rook B eight. When I
say pre move, I mean premove.
Even if White plays G four,
you still play rook A B eight.
And if White plays, G takes f five.
Just queen B. Four. You don't
even need to sack on B two. Just go. Queen b
four.   B three.
And now
bishop takes C three is a very
bad move because of queen to D six covering
the A three square. You actually want to go
rook B to D eight,
forcing the queen away. And if
White plays queen takes D eight, then we
play   queen A three,
check. If the king moves up to D two, then
we take the queen. And here we
take C three. And checkmate
is unavoidable on B two.
So nothing insane, but
a pretty nice line and a good line to
know. So if we rewind
BC E five, N G eight,
F four, you redeploy the knight to H
six. This is how quickly White can
go down, unless White plays a
bunch of computer moves. And the objective
assessment of this position is equal. The
engine gives zero zero, but
the top engine move is something nobody's
going to play. I don't think anybody's going
to go H three here. I think most people are
going to go queen d two. The second most
popular move here is bishop d three.
Again, black's
continuation is
usually   reliably the same you
castle and then you play d six
to try to get rid of that e five
pawn. And once you get rid of
it, white is left with a ton
of weaknesses. Black is left with
a semi open b file and this pawn and a four
sticks out like a sore thumb.
Actually, even stronger is
to play ng four. Intermediate
move    bishop d two in the
classic bishop d four, king h one
night f two check wins in exchange. But, uh,
this is actually the top engine suggestion.
An important detail
here. Queen e two forks, the
bishop and the pond. But the bishop
can drop back to c five x ray defending
e seven. And black is fine here.
Black is much better actually up in
exchange. So anyways,
that's another way
for white to be worse after an
IGA. White can
also try the move bishop to d
four, which is almost as popular
as f four. And here you have to know the
move queen to a five, get the queen out.
And there is a very important
line where white plays the
move e six. And again, if you don't know the
theory, it's easy to get overwhelmed
here because you can't
take the pawn because you dropped the
bishop. And a mistake would be to take the
bishop, allowing white to get the queen
into d four and hit the rook in the corner.
So instead, all you have to do
here is get the night out to f six. Night f
six, and black is better. And
black is better because even though the
king gets out to f seven, it's perfectly
safe here. And black has a massive
pawn center.
Bishop c four check is met with d
five.   And if bishop b
three,   then black has an
incredibly strong move here, which is a
direct product of white delaying the
castling. Who can spot this move? Kind
of a classic idea.
Yeah, it's e five. It's
e five. This is an important
move to have in your sort of toolkit.
And if white takes on e five,
some two hundreds, 23 hundreds have
played like this rookie eight.
White has to play f four.
And now I like the top
engine move. Nike four is
great.   Also good is the
move queen to b six to prevent white
from castling.    And
if queen f three, you
prevent white from castling queen's
side by playing this mysterious
looking move bishop to h six.
But it's not mysterious if
you consider how you prevent castling. Now,
you can take e five upon enough
forest pint, so you've prevented white
from castling either side. And now the king
is stuck in the center where it is going to
be massacred by a
combination of forces. Nike four, bishop a
ah six is going to be very
strong. This is like minus plus.
And White's pieces are biting on granite
on D five.   That's
another nice line.
If White takes the other way, E takes D
seven, well, then
black plays bishop takes D seven.
Check.   And for example,
if white plays bishop to C
four,   very strong. Here is the
move bishop to G four   with the idea
of meeting F three. Another trick with rook
to D eight.   And if FG
four, C five and you're going to lose the
bishop on D four, black is going to get a
devastating initiative here.
Just devastating.  One
thing you should never be afraid of in these
types of positions is moving your king. It's
okay to move your king because White is
getting crushed in the center
castle's CD. And white
loses a minor piece because if the knight
moves, you lose the bishop. Otherwise, black
takes the night. The rook on D eight is
protected.  So
this is a short
overview of what to do
after knight takes E six and E five, which
are definitely going to face if you play the
accelerated dragon for any length of time.
All right, so in the game,
our opponent plays this
move, A three, which is obviously
a very strange
move. It's not a very good move. I see
that it has been played a fair number of
times.    But
I think bishop C four is a
follow up mistake after which White
is simply in huge
trouble. I mean, White should probably go
bishop E two to avoid
the center fork trick. But even here,
even here,
um,   black, I think,
should just go D five.
And black is definitely slightly better.
I mean, white has literally just wasted a
move for no reason. I see that
seven games continued ed five, Nd five,
NC six, PC. And you should never
be afraid of this pawn structure
in the accelerated dragon because it's
compensated by the
tremendous activity of your pieces.
If you look at the knight and your bishop,
they're both aiming at the night on C three.
White is in trouble here. If
Bishop D four, then you can
play knight takes C three and White is
forced to ruin their pawn structure.
For example, Bishop C three,
now you trade. Now you get your
queen to a five.
And the attack on C three is
very powerful. The rook is coming to D
eight. This is again, minus over plus
is the evaluation here.
So everywhere you look, black is
already better here. But bishop C
four exacerbates the situation
because of knight takes C four.
And,   uh, I
wouldn't say that the game is over, but it's
definitely    borderline
lost for White. Perhaps
white should play bishop takes F seven.
Check.   And you should remember
that when you face the center fork
trick,  the recommendation
is usually to do what our opponent did,
or no, not to do what our opponent did. The
recommendation, when you're facing the
center fork trick, uh, in most
openings is to keep your bishop pair with a
move bishop to D three. So, for
instance for instance,
let me take another opening where the center
fork trick is common.
Let's take a very primitive example.
So in the four nights,
if you play Bishop C four, black has the
move knight takes C four.
And here, after knight takes
C,
only way for White to not be worse
is to play this move
bishop to D three
and Black has to recapture.
And then White is able to
preserve the bishop pair. And white is doing
okay. Here the position is equal.
Okay,    I can show
you in the perk, right in the perk,
there's a line
where     essentially
here,     whatever bishops E
four. Castles, castles.
Here, black can take on E four.
And again, in this position,
the best move for White is Bishop to D
three.   De Bishop e
four. And White is considered a little bit
better in this line.   But if we
compare this to the position we had in our
game, white essentially cannot do the
same thing. Because if White plays
Bishop D three here, then
we actually can take the other knight and
we're just a pawn up.   And
if White takes first and
then plays Bishop D three, which
might have been the lesser evil,
this might have been the best that White can
do. But here, in addition to
taking the spawn, after which White
is much worse, the
engine actually recommends the
devilish move bishop to a six,
preventing White from castling
and keeping the king confined in the
center. And if White takes bishop C
six, now we play bishop B
two. And if White takes the
rook, we give a nice little
check on a five. And look at
this line. If Queen D two,
bishop C three wins the queen.
If Bishop D two, the
queen swings to E five,
then the bishop drops back to C three.
And again, White loses the queen in all of
his other pieces.   So
this is the power of preventing your
opponent from castling when you
yourself are castled and in total
safety.
So anyways,
this is why Bishop D three is not
possible here.
Now, our
opponent's choice definitely made things
worse for her, I think. Probably White
should just castle here. Probably White
should just castle here. And after
DC, I mean, at least White's King is not
unsafe. Of course we're still up
upon we still have an attack on B
two. It's minus plus. But of course the
game continues. Sometimes you just got
to castle out of it.
White went into this endgame, but as it
turns out, this endgame is just totally
lost because the attack on B two
is completely unstoppable. I
mean, White probably has to play this
move to stave off immediate
defeat. But we're not even going to talk
about this. Black is up a pawn here, and
White is completely paralyzed. And you
could even carry. Out a similar
idea to what we did in the game. You could
play like F five and
then E five and creep up with your pawns
in the center. And White is just, uh,
totally out of squares.
So this is this is awful.
Okay, rugby one, bishop takes E three. The
game is over immediately, and we don't have
to talk about the rest.   Uh,
so,   pretty one sided,
but a good introduction to the
accelerated dragon. As you can see, even
at this level, a lot of players
feel very lost on the
white side of the accelerated because it's
not the most common Sicilian and it's not
that often taught.   And, uh,
hopefully this gave you a good
illustration of some of the
introductory lines. Especially we talked
about knight takes C six at length, but
the key thing to remember is you're not
afraid to bring the knight back to G eight.
And don't be afraid to analyze this with an
engine on your own as well.   The main line,
by the way, the main line here is
bishop C four castles, and then
Bishop back to B three.
Why does white need Bishop B three? Well,
you already know the reason for that. Here.
Black again has the center fork
trick with 94. And by
contrast to the game
continuation, this is a better version
for White. And here, White can in fact, play
bishop D three and reach this
position. But it is considered that black is
even slightly better after queen C
seven because you get the semi
open B file, you get the D file,
and the accelerated bishop on G seven is
just super, super strong here.
But hopefully I will
even make Morocc's kind of
interesting.   All right,
let's
get in another game unless there are any
questions. This was a very
straightforward one,
but   I can't control how our opponents
play. We can only control how we
play.    All right,
hope you enjoyed the speedrun. Bye.
You.